who just walked in she knew that we were
going live she's just kind of like hey
hey everybody it's Saturday and we
decided to do we haven't watched any new
movies so we couldn't do a matinee show
yet we're gonna watch some new movies
tonight I guess we can do a matinee
tomorrow live so we decided to just do a
sidetracks because there's a couple
little things that we wanted to talk
about so one of the first things I
wanted to talk about remember like this
was probably like last year sometime but
I said that I was consolidating a lot of
my fiction and I was doing like
audiobook versions of it and all this
other kind of stuff and I actually did
manage to get the Associated villanies
my 2011 book I actually did manage to do
a second edition of that and do an audio
version of that and get that up but then
while I was working on the second one
hopeful monsters I kind of got
sidetracked by all these other projects
and I didn't get to it but then like the
other day I was like looking through all
the stuff cuz I'd been recording some of
the stories for the witching hour and
stuff and I was just kind of like well
[ __ ] I only have like two or three
stories left to read on that and then
the audiobook will be done so I'm really
into like really crack down and get you
know the last stories recorded and
edited and then get the second edition
like the print in the e-book put up and
then subsequently put the audiobook up
cuz the audiobook takes usually takes
like two or three weeks like after the
print goes up so that'll be a new thing
that I have going on so after we
finished recording this I might like
actually do some recording and maybe try
to finish editing it tomorrow um I also
yeah we got a whole bunch of people yay
Niko he's nest Dom the bomb Deborah
mango badger
yuria Sandra Tammy and Melissa how you
guys doing hey everybody nice to see
y'all alright yeah we got kind of
updates and stuff going on don't we yes
somebody told me I think it was Sandra
actually that she told me this morning
there had been yet another update in the
valo de Bell case which we did I think
the last time we did aside tracks we
talked about that they had actually
found the body
unfortunately of the timely Ryan and JJ
ballo who disappeared last year or the
year before now what they I guess the
authorities have put out now because
like I said Chad de Belle and Laurie
fallow are still in custody although
neither of them have been charged with
murder yet
Laurie valo is in there for like child
abandonment various other things and
Chad de bellas in there for you know
hiding evidence essentially since the
bodies were found in his backyard so the
information that they've just released
today was that the reason that they knew
to look in chad de belles backyard for
the bodies was that they had been
investigating pings
on Alex Cox's cellphone and that they
thought it was very weird that these
pings were coming like the backyard and
all this other kind stuff so that's how
they knew how to where to look so it
does seem like Alex Cox who is Laurie
Val O's brother he is deceased however
he was one of the main suspects and well
he died actually did shoot like one of
their family members right but he got
away with it because it was like
self-defense and then chad de belles
first wife also died which was also very
suspicious so i think that they're
operating from what i could determine
they seem like they're operating under
the assumption that Alex Cox was kind of
these two crazy peoples like hitman I
guess he was like the dude that they
went to like when they wanted someone
dead or out of the way or whatever time
you say [ __ ] man Zachary's out there
Freddie Mercury ami oh we should talk
about that too because we watched that
documentary we love you too yeah you
guys are like all our best comedy trying
to get me to say crazy [ __ ] I know you
guys know you guys say crazy [ __ ] to try
to get me to say crazy [ __ ] cuz you know
I'm gonna try to up the ante that's
right ah I got when I come off a stream
I have to have said the craziest [ __ ]
yeah easier than anybody else's [ __ ] yes
they keep liked it I gotta stay on top
of it
you were mostly
I don't know I know you did good though
you stayed pretty cuz we recorded like
the main episode last night it's another
trick crime episode but I'm not gonna
say like what it is an almost spoil
that's for everybody but it's gonna go
up on Tuesday like regular now we said
on that show that you know as I said you
the live streams have been working out
well with the side tracks and with the
matinee is that seems like to be the
best thing to do for a live stream but I
still do want to do at least one or two
episodes like regular episodes every
month as a live stream it will probably
be on a Friday night or Saturday night
depending on what else we got going on
or anything like that but this one that
we've already recorded it so it's gonna
go up on Tuesday we recorded it last
night but yeah so this dude so Alex
Cox's cellphone apparently so was they
had like tracked it as being in chad de
belles backyard at like 921 and it's
like he seemed like he was always there
like the last day that the kids were
seen and then later and then he came up
with this weird story that he texted
them and said there was a raccoon in the
backyard and he had killed it and buried
it in the pet cemetery dan and then he
said stuff like ooh the girl was
dismembered [ __ ] burned they have it
you know what I mean it's like I was
reading because I there was an article
on CNN there was one like in a couple of
other ones and they all said pretty much
the same thing but as far as I know
unless they've updated it like in the
last couple of hours they haven't
exactly said how the kids died like what
the cause of death was so it's clearly
it's it's not good it's you know I'm
just trying to give me take my shirt off
again Zach Zach yeah
Jack's out there getting this [ __ ]
wallet credit card I ain't gonna make it
I'm not gonna make a [ __ ] I'm not
gonna make a living as a hotline [ __ ]
I'm not I'm not that kind of over the
years yeah but yeah so another thing too
that came out and I don't know if this
was in any of the original [ __ ] about
this case but that
so apparently Laurie valo and Chad de
Belle they were what is that [ __ ] what
are they like um what'swhat's the people
that are think that they're part of the
hundred and forty-four thousand people
that are getting raptured up or whatever
is that that is that J was witness or
Hyundai Adventists or a lot of them
believe that do you ever forty I thought
it was like one particularly um heart it
was computed by you know there's a lot
of self-styled preachers and yeah that's
happened over the years and just their
interpretation of revelations I I
believe it actually says a hundred and
forty four thousand or was computed to
be a hundred that's yeah I think it was
a computation that long and came and
that that's who would be raptured number
correctly I think it was just was it
raptured of those who actually went to
heaven after and then everyone else is
your vessel your [ __ ] yeah cuz in some
in some interpretations you don't mean
like only a very small amount of people
go to heaven the rest of them it's very
like exclusive yes yeah that's where the
Angels live yeah made for human souls
okay the rest of the you know when you
throw in the Old Testament and
everything with the concept of she all
and everything you're actually just
supposed to die and go to the grave it's
kind of like gloom or to live like
spooky ghosts in the grave kind of like
that's the not I want to be a spooky
ghost in the whole
now it is also kind of some Christians
that said well there's another option
and that's to go back to Eden and that
and there's in Revelation Conda ends
with good people back in Eden that's one
idea so some of them in haven't filling
of them in eat forever naked with the
fig trees well guys it has to do with
the Neuse New Jerusalem in a new city
coming down made out of jewels yeah and
then people living in it with new bodies
and stuff so they're certain they're
thinking it's it's like a New Eden
yeah and that the saved go there most of
them yeah all right most of the saved go
there some of them go to heaven but most
people throughout history go to Sheol
yeah which is the the grave ok which is
either interpreted of like eternal sleep
or you know there's been different ideas
of what that is the whole hell thing is
actually kind of based on only like a
couple little books well that's kind of
a later interpolation yeah one one of
the prophets one of the prophets [ __ ]
some is able to talk to somebody who's
dead and that person is in hell and
asked for a little bit of water that's
one thing when they said well there's a
Hell there and then there's also a lake
of fire that the dragon is cast into in
so they say well that's hell - yeah but
seems to be that hell is reserved only
for the dragon out of that story well
they made that whole thing just for that
one dragon yeah a dragon with a giant
ass just like an abyss it's the the Old
Testament in the New Testament course
their patchwork quilts of a bunch of
different books yeah it kind of like
yeah it that cobbled together cobbled
together the afterlife the heavenly
realms and the hellish realms it's
inconsistent the descriptions are
inconsistent so they made up a bunch of
different ones yeah that's all over the
place yeah seven heavens seven different
kinds of heavens Eden's and then a whole
bunch of different kinds of hell's yes
that's assistant to the [ __ ] milieu
of the show
of the day in which all this [ __ ] was
written because every religion and every
little cult had their own different
version of what a hell or heaven was so
in the end the Christians Christians
kind of synthesized it all and yeah it's
all there yeah which is a Roman concept
so these two whack jobs well not only do
they believe in the 144,000 thing they
also have this other thing where they
think that there are things that they
call zombies which are not living dead
what they they're like dark spirits and
allegedly several members of you know
are several friends or acquaintances of
this couple have said that Laurie valo
told them that JJ the little boy who was
7 was a zombie and also that the 17 year
old girl Ty Lee was also a zombie which
they actually did believe that these
kids had like dark spirits or dark souls
and needed to be destroyed evidently so
that's kind of what they've cuz they
thought that that was their mission in
life which should destroy zombies not
like Walking Dead zombies but like
people with evil spirits inside them so
that seems to be what the motivation was
at least according to a bunch of people
that knew them that came forward and
said that that they that they had
thought said that the kids were zombies
you know what I mean which that's like
their whole mission in life was to rid
the world of zombies yeah Maria
mentioned something is kind of
interesting that Adam being made of mud
is basically what you're talking about
is the [ __ ] Jewish golem spell yeah
yeah the witch that's that's that's
correct
that's how God's created everything and
yeah and then the Johnson crap the
concept of a golem is like well you
might be able to figure out how to do if
you're a man or a wizard you might build
a figure to have it do that to turn you
know bring something to life yeah just
it's like some Frankenstein [ __ ] right
if you don't even need like to dig up
any bodies you could just like make a
little clay make a snowman and then look
pretty too like I think that's why in
Islam they do kind of ban all statues
because they're afraid that someone's
gonna
make a go animate it yeah you might that
make sense you might actually be able to
bring a god to life because people know
Romans made statues of gods constantly
and any they made it statues could move
which was like bringing a statue to life
Ray Harryhausen Jerry did we hear most
of you real high technology that the
Romans did have was applied to religion
[ __ ] like coin operated stuff and
[ __ ] animatronics and [ __ ] around
with concepts like speakers and speaking
tubes to make statues talk and move
which impressed people of the day today
you laugh at it well yeah but it's like
back then that probably would have been
really impressive because it's like if
you didn't know if you were just kind of
like some dude living on a farm that
didn't know how to read or anything like
that yeah and somebody trucks into town
with a statue that could talk and like
move around and stuff you know it was it
would be was in these real expensive
high-tech temples too they did what they
weren't moving you know a traveling show
this is [ __ ] expensive [ __ ] and they
were high off they were tripping balls
they were they were high as hell we
don't know exactly what they were taken
yeah but it's described they were
drinking certain things that made the
experience a lot more intense so it was
some psychedelic and cults of Bacchus
and [ __ ] you know it's all about
drinking wine and drinking yourself into
a damn frenzy and partying so that was
kind of like a nightclub it's like a
rave yeah
back I just got complete face yeah face
and dancing and [ __ ] sex and stuff
you know putting on shows and you know
all the religions were kind of like a
show and you know you can even look at
Christian services you could see that
that descended from shows and the way
things are written in Pauline epistles
you know stuff like and we see before us
you know Jesus having been put up and
crucified by the powers and
principalities you know there well we
are seeing before us as portrayed as
crucified they're talking about we saw
the show we saw him portrayed as
crucified right
that's what they're talking about you
guys see that you see that [ __ ] when we
go to church we see Jesus as portrayed
as crucified by the powers of
principalities of the earth and the
powers and principalities of the earth
goes back to the book of Genesis you
know where you had buck in L or L to die
also known as God Almighty and his sons
and each one of them choosing a tribe
and Yahweh chooses Israel so and there
are the powers and principalities of the
earth so what you're talking about is
the Demiurge sky demons the sons of God
you know and the sons of God had sex
with the daughters of women and they
became demigods this is the same thing
that the Greeks believed yeah not too
far off
yeah same [ __ ] I was just on his son so
just laughing at the Beast that's movie
coming it says Roman said ecstasy and
techno music [ __ ] yeah I believe it
probably did now I'm thinking of like
all the ancient Romans and Chinese and
they all had like [ __ ] glow sticks
there's some evidence that they had an
ability to write music down although I
don't you know just must have been
pretty crude yeah cuz I don't think like
musical notation that wasn't too much
later that came along but they found
some stones a head tucking symbols and
[ __ ] and some people they thought it
might have been some kind of a code
language yeah but other people looked at
it there were musicians and they thought
that it was it it looked like snow who's
like a crude musical notation new school
notation that would make sense because
you would think that they would have
some way of doing that even if it wasn't
as sophisticated as later right somebody
said that we should do Maria says we
should do a show about Caligula we
should actually yeah we haven't done
Caligula yeah it did we did um like we
did like the look at Stowe the poisoner
and like some other room and stuff but
we didn't do Caligula's [ __ ] weird
because you know his uncle Tiberius had
him as a sex slave out there on the
[ __ ] isla tupiri and that's how he
grew up you know watching little kids
being thrown off a damn [ __ ] cliffs
when they were acting bad for not a
little bit of childhood and and you know
his whole
family had been wiped out by Tiberius
he's kind of kept as a pet and Caligula
ended up inheriting the [ __ ] throne
of [ __ ] the Roman Empire that's a
[ __ ] dangerous
dangerous situation if I can give power
to somebody like that been victimized
but she went insane know how that worked
I was talking to gods and doing all
kinds of weird drugs and [ __ ] doing
crazy [ __ ] and [ __ ] and he didn't
like the ruling class which ran Rome and
you know I think I think a lot of it was
I think he was insane mentally in a bad
mental health and then he started doing
[ __ ] like eating a lot of lead they they
had a lot of lead and they dined on lead
stuff and they probably ate lead because
they liked how the lead tasted and it
sounds like lead poisoning yeah a lot of
the [ __ ] that he did that would explain
a lot he would go into convulsions he
went into convulsions one time when he
came out he was [ __ ] [ __ ] up and
that's really when his behavior got
really bad something happened some I
think it might have been lead poisoning
and maybe he had some brain hemorrhages
and it burned out certain parts of his
brain is he the one with the party barge
yeah memory bar she had two party barges
yeah they were badass yeah they were
gigantic yeah Mussolini found him when
he drained the [ __ ] Lake yeah that's
right I said I remember seeing a
documentary about them yeah and you
looked at him and like the fixtures and
the plumbing and it looked like
something out of the 1920s you know they
had very very good technology much
better than people think yeah and the
ability to [ __ ] cast things they
probably mass-produced things they
definitely mass-produced plumbing pipes
and stuff and they seemed to
mass-produced certain Terry 'its
if they'd had gunpowder they would have
been able to easily mass-produce guns I
just didn't have gunpowder yeah they
were on a verge of a industrial
revolution but what held him back was
the their economy was kind of slave
powered so there wasn't any need for any
labor-saving devices you know you could
just put German
in the field and work them it was a lot
cheaper than making a machine and
because they were in sourcing all the
labor or outsourcing the labor to slaves
it [ __ ] up the the Roman economy there
was no middle class and they're veterans
weren't getting their [ __ ] paychecks
which caused the budget how it breaks
the [ __ ] civil wars very similar to
the United States outsourcing all the
jobs to China it's it's it's a common
thread it's common theme of the rich
trying to get richer by eliminating its
own population yeah that way they're
sidestepped labor unions and but had
they not taken a bunch of German slaves
and kept them as workers they probably
would have made labor saving devices
which that put us 2,000 years ahead in
technology today yeah they were on the
verge of it they were kind of mass
producing wheat and grains making flour
such are the vicissitudes if they needed
a train system they had steam power but
they needed a train system to have rapid
response for foreign attack and rapid
transit of [ __ ] materials but they
built aqueducts and built roads but for
some reason never applied steam power to
two vehicles which they that you think
that would have good like a make you
hadn't made a huge difference they would
have had they would have held together a
lot longer if they'd had trains and
really they weren't that far from
understanding because they could
electroplate a little bit they really
weren't that far from the telegraph and
had they yeah they had that then you'd
have mass transit and mass communication
you'd have [ __ ] telecommunications
and that would that would have [ __ ]
made Rome survive it would have survived
yeah world would have been a lot have
been a lot different today today
whatever in like an alternate history
and the reason why you fail greed yeah
greed in the ruling class that always
that's what did it yeah thing yep I
wanted to I know this is kind of like
out of left field but I just saw this
little story today and this kind of
I don't know this kind of like warms the
cockles of my heart oh man it sounds
nice you know he's got cockles just
because I like a little story about some
little guys that are like man I'm just
gonna do this thing and they like they
were able to do it like especially like
you know considering like not really
taking advantage of kind of a shitty
situation but sort of so it's these two
guys Christian Nelson and Eric taboc I
guess that's how you pronounce it he's a
youtuber and they wondered they're like
you know since a lot of movie theaters
are closed or like really diminished
capacity because of coronavirus it's
like I wonder could we like just make a
zero budget horror movie and get it into
a theater and make it be the number one
movie for at least one day they just
wanted to do that so what they did is
they were like okay so I guess there's
some kind of thing where if you're like
the distributor of a movie like I don't
know if you get like a certain amount or
I don't know how it works or anything
like that but they said well what we
wanted to do was we wanted to just like
have one theater and rent it out and
show our movie even if nobody's that
we're just gonna buy all the tickets
ourselves and we just want to see if we
could get to like the number one spot in
America like on the movie rankings so
what they did was they hadn't they
didn't even have a movie this wasn't a
thing where they had admit like made a
movie and they're just like we're gonna
show it and saying they hadn't even made
a movie they just wondered if they could
do it so what they did was they spent a
week and they made a half-hour horror
film and it's called unsubscribe and it
takes place entirely over zoom they just
got like a bunch of they had like a
couple of actors I think one guy that
was in Oz arc that showed that son
Netflix and a couple of other youtubers
they knew so they just basically got
everyone together on zoom and mate I
haven't seen it so I don't know if it's
any good but like he wrote it and filmed
it in like a week and they just did it
all over video chat and then so he makes
the movie then they pulled a bunch of
their money together rented one theater
in Long Island and bought every single
ticket and that ended up being a one day
$25,000 you know
Theatre like it was like that was like
the take for that day and indeed it was
just a Wednesday it wasn't like a
weekend or anything like that but indeed
unsubscribe a half hour movie made for
like nothing was the number one movie in
the United States that particular day
just because they wanted to see if they
could do it you can also like I said you
can also rent it on Vimeo apparently I
think like I said it's only half an hour
long but it cost them like nothing to
make but I just thought that was so so
funny
and honestly it costs them money I guess
in the end but I'm imagining that the
publicity around it will make more
people rent it so maybe it was a smart
idea after all maybe it was just kind of
like an investment that they decided to
make you know what I mean so I just
thought that was like a very funny thing
that they wanted to see if they could do
it since most of the theaters were
closed and you know this so they just
got in under the radar which I thought
was very funny another thing we could
talk about very briefly if you want for
free on YouTube because we were like I
was kind of going through looking for
[ __ ] that was free on YouTube to watch
and we just kind of landed on a
documentary about Freddie Mercury yeah
what was it called like the king of
Queen I think so yeah yeah it's like
free to watch and I had never seen it
it's and yeah it was actually like
really really good have you seen the
bunny media Rhapsody movie it's uh it's
not as good as that of course but you
know I mean that can if you enjoyed that
you'd like you to enjoy this - yeah it's
like a bunch of people that knew a man
like you know that Bohemian Rhapsody
movie is really good I got it on blu-ray
yeah yes really we saw it a couple times
in the theater right they reacted that
come I'm a mess just like [ __ ] Freddie
Mercury
yeah real thing yeah he did a really
good job well didn't I think last year
or whatever that movie came out like
didn't I think that might have one no
thank you and best fiction goes well uh
Remi Malik one I think he won Best Actor
though playing Freddie Mercury I think
Green Book won best picture didn't it
come on I can't remember what year I
lost ring somebody else there was a
Freddie Mercury impersonator that's
saying it sounds just like him but he
did the [ __ ] live show he really sold
it because you know we grew up we grew
up we saw Live Aid when it happened yeah
I watched like
back in time like seeing it again I mean
that was some crazy [ __ ] and I was like
I can't remember now cuz I couldn't
watch the whole thing obviously because
it was like hours hours long I was I was
watching to see like Duran Duran and
some of the other bands
yeah it's bunch of good bands but I
can't remember who had to go after Queen
but I kind of feel like that must have
really sucked a lot like they must
whoever that band was I can't remember
like offhand but they must be backstage
like watching that after the like Queen
came off there was like [ __ ] I was
not a huge queen fan at the time I knew
they were good I like a lot of their
songs by her United known any of their
albums or anything um but I remember
that show live watching it live and then
him just it was like a mic drop like
[ __ ] that he walks off that was it was
like the best live performances ever
it's just looking great and like you
said you wouldn't you would hate to go
on next after that yeah I would have
really hated that now I'm now I'm gonna
have to go look up cuz I can't remember
what the lineup was for a Live Aid but
uh yeah I wouldn't have liked to have to
follow that because I mean really he was
just kind of like we were talking about
this the cool thing about Freddie
Mercury was that he seemed like he
seemed confident without being arrogant
you know what I mean and he was like
really over the top and really but he
came across also you could tell that he
was just like a nice dude you know what
I mean which a lot of people that knew
him said like everybody said he was just
a lovely person so he didn't come across
as like really cocky or anything like
that he just kind of and it's kind of
amazing how he entirely like invented
himself essentially you know what I mean
like being from Zanzibar and you know
there but never been a rock star from
there or anything like that and just
kind of through the power of his will
and like just knowing how to reinvent
himself and you know being really
musically talented having like an
amazing voice um that easily one of the
best voices and rock you know he just
kind of mango badger says he thought it
was the Houthi that came on after them
oh it might have been yeah I'd have to
lie back enough to who I don't know why
that who was famous I didn't like the
who oh I do I didn't like them I thought
they were very mediocre they're not my
favorite but I did like them there were
that kind of sucked honor I remember
like I said because I was a big Duran
Duran fan at the time because it was
1985 right so I wanted to see them and I
remember very clearly that is you know
it's Live Aid there's millions of people
watching around the world it's like for
charity and everything like that and
they were singing Duran Duran were
singing I think it was a view to a kill
and Simon's voice cracked like on a high
note and it was really and like for many
years afterward he was just kind of like
every like every time he had an
interview they always asked him about so
how did it feel to have your voice [ __ ]
up in front of like 50 bajillion people
on earth I was like oh man that would
have sucked so bad because I just like
[ __ ] cringed when that happened he
wasn't that great life didn't do it but
he was much better in the studio of
course here Simon he well he has an
interesting voice he's not real I mean I
guess he gotta compete could pull it off
yeah he was a singer when he was a kid
like he sang in a choir and also I had
forgotten all about this because I used
to know everything there was to know
about during Duran and I forgot about it
but he was in like um commercials and he
was a kid he was like a child actor
because I remember he was in a
commercial for Percel which is like a
like a dish soap like in the UK yeah he
was in that way like when he was a
little boy like six or seven I just
remember that Live Aid era that's when I
think sting I had just come out still
kind of knew he was a new he was newly
solo but now right is it coz yeah I
think his first solo yeah an 85 or I
Riddick's I really liked the police but
then when he started doing solo stuff I
mean he had some good hits he did yeah
but but by that time he had gotten so
[ __ ] pretentious that I kind of
[ __ ] didn't like it he did go a
little dream of the blue turtles I had
that oh yeah yeah it was pretty good you
know I mean I liked his solo stuff too
but it's just he was becoming [ __ ]
insufferable yeah he'd show up on
television just so [ __ ] pretentious
like mad [ __ ]
I'm sorry to take him seriously and the
same thing happens if I can do it you
too
yeah bono and all the guys to this [ __ ]
they got a little update well I feel
like when sting was in a band you know
you're a [ __ ] at your worst impulses a
tempered a little bit did you have like
two other guys go man that's not that
[ __ ] off yeah but we just will be
recently saw sting in that LSD
documentary and he seemed alright then
he owned it down a bit tone down the
provision I would say that is the last
time that's the last time I've seen him
a long time because I think we were
talking about in the other day it's like
we haven't seen him and so long like did
he get fat he doesn't come out in the
public anymore but now he's no I'm
saying he still looks good he still
looks the same as the last I think he
just can't really go out because people
take a piss out of him yeah maybe
celebrities not what it was yeah I
wonder if he I act that way anymore
I wonder still when he goes out do
people still ask him about that like
that weird kamasutra does anybody
remember that anymore I don't doubt it
well I don't know if younger people that
would take the piss out of him like
that's trying to be some kind of [ __ ]
Eastern guru yeah it was like [ __ ]
wasn't Henry Rollins trying to tell
people how to [ __ ] ones with Henry right
doesn't sound like Islands were [ __ ]
Glenn Danzig around that same time I
don't know can uh I don't need Glenda I
like Glenn no I like his music that is
[ __ ] he needed to get out he's a
little douchey I was he was up himself
yeah which you know you have to have a
little bit of a sense of humor about him
you know you can't take yourself too
seriously but no I think it was Henry
Henry Rollins trying yeah
we did I don't think I was trying to
explain to dudes how to how they should
make love to women people told a
fuck-off make love the Henry Rollins way
it's not like well then oh that was a
bruce campbell look make love the bruce
campbell way but it was it wasn't you
actually about to cry shot that he was
just being funny he probably got that
from [ __ ] his Bruce because Bruce
Campbell is a delightful human being and
I've read all his books and he is like
really super funny somebody asked if we
had ever played D&D a few times when I
was younger yeah and we played once on a
podcast it wasn't it actually wasn't D&D
but it was another game like that it was
back in the very early 80s there too
it's I'm getting too old to like
remember like all because there's too
many rules man it's just like well now
it's like six points for that and hip
points for that it's like what I don't
back around back in 80 81 when that [ __ ]
was [ __ ] real popular for guys my age
you were like at the time like 13 maybe
yeah 13 we buy those books we buy those
lead figurines we paint him up we'd read
those books we knew it but we didn't
ever get ever actually really get
together and play it that much yeah it
was mostly just about reading those two
[ __ ] oh yeah I just liked the books
and like seeing all the creatures and
yeah that'll figurine coming up with
stories it was guys that were a little
bit older than us that we're actually
playing it yeah and man computers got
rid of all that just a few years later
you know [ __ ] Apple Apple - computer
had something called wizardry which is a
video game that really simplified a lot
of that it was kind of like a rack of
[ __ ] for you yeah it was kind of like it
was like playing D&D but the computer
was the dungeon master yeah it was a lot
more reliable because when your friend
was a dungeon master most like a cheat
or he'd help you live through it you
know I mean and and then you started off
first level your [ __ ] character was
so [ __ ] weak if you breathe too hard
you know and everything is too expensive
you couldn't buy any of the weapons and
[ __ ] really just and then all the
modules all the real cool modules that
came out from my Gary Gygax on Khan [ __ ]
they were for character
like [ __ ] fifteenth level yeah 20th
level yeah you couldn't really have fun
with it until you had some ass yeah
hours
yeah are some good weapons because other
than that you were just like a tiny
little infant like walking around
stepped on by every single monster they
hit they had this one [ __ ] module
that was just like nearly impossible to
get through I think it was called like
the tomb of horror I think is what was
called you wanted to be like [ __ ]
20th level and it was like the tomb of a
of a lich and there weren't any monsters
and it was just nothing but [ __ ]
traps traps and [ __ ] puzzles that
[ __ ] was hard see that sounded like
more my speed we did play that one but
we know we invented characters who were
already like [ __ ] 15th level ones
yeah like I said you got to you got yeah
I don't have the patience to like
actually like we got we got room where
we got through maybe like one third of
it and that took like probably about
four days like four weekends
yeah like to get through about one third
of it but man is [ __ ] near impossible
I mean you open the wrong thing and you
vanish everybody dies well you guys
would have died so but I don't want to
start over at the beginning so yeah yes
so we're gonna pretend like you guys
picked the other yeah are you playing
the game or you're not playing the game
so dungeon dragons was most offensive
people pretended it they were playing
more than anything else well like I said
I think I I enjoyed it more like I
enjoyed like Dungeons and Dragons style
games like when we had a PC like we had
King's Quest which actually I really
liked that was you know a similar kind
of fantasy game and it was puzzles and
monster [ __ ] like that I like that kind
of thing because it kept track of all
the [ __ ] for you and it's like if you
[ __ ] up you could start over like a
little bit back Zac said that he had
actually made a indie horror movie about
D&D Player's and somebody said something
about yeah cuz the 80s like Dungeons &
Dragons somebody said I heard in a chick
tract that just attract kids is really
bad yeah it was like really part of the
satanic panic thing which I didn't even
do that on purpose like we're in this
shirt today
but yeah that was um yeah the books used
to be they were really big and hardback
I guess are they still they were when I
was like the dungeon master manuals work
yeah because I had a couple other there
were two different versions of tons of
dragons there was Advanced Dungeons and
Dragons that was all the hardcover stuff
yeah Jules was so soft yeah that's right
and then there was basic Dungeons and
Dragons which was a simpler way of doing
it and I knew both ways
yeah you know the basic D&D eliminated a
lot of the [ __ ] little details so you
could start playing a lot faster yeah
you could get into a dungeon master
could figure it out you know in about
six months baby yeah you know how to do
it and it was weird because they were
kind of amateurishly written that the
rule books so you had to read the entire
book before you could kind of compiled
how that game worked yeah you know I
mean it didn't they really explained it
as it went they weren't really well
written I mean just the way it was you
know yeah because there's anonymous
automaton said in the 80s she needed to
be 18 to buy the books and the dice
because they said the indie would make
you go crazy I remember that I don't
remember that yeah I remember that being
lousy at that I was mazes and monsters
that movie with Tom Hanks when he was
really young like about somebody like
killing themselves ever I can't believe
what happens in it I think it's free on
Toby this was 80 81 when I played it in
California and that game came from
California I think and all the little
yeah Bobby shops had it yep there was no
concept of D&D being something that was
dangerous or bad that that did not exist
in California yeah not that time that
was outside California California was
just a it was just when you went to a
model shop or a comic shop or something
it had that in it it had the Dungeons &
Dragons little figures and it had the
the games but they also had little bitty
cast iron or latina cast her a little
bitty lead or plastic Star Trek ships
because there was a game played on his
big black hex maps having something to
do with Star Trek yeah I know what
you're talking about I'll remember what
it was called oh [ __ ] man they had the
ships from all the Star Trek oh yeah
we're not talking about next generation
before the next generation we hung out
Star Trek ships from the original series
right and [ __ ] that you had never seen
before that was from posed to be from
the original series they did have some
of the stuff from the very early movies
like Star Trek one two and three yeah
and the ships from those two and it was
some kind of [ __ ]
Star Trek boys at Starfleet battles I
mean that was called yeah I think that
might have been what it was it was a
Star Trek based war game and that was
[ __ ] hugely popular right along I
remember hearing about that one right
alongside start Dungeons & Dragons they
would keep track with you know photon
torpedoes you know inside the ship and
fleets and just a war game they also did
it with tanks yeah dead tank wargames oh
we had one like I think my brother had
one like that yeah a little model tanks
yeah yeah on hex maps they even had
these places where and it was those old
guys that was guys World War two
veterans playing that one yeah some of
it was also a civil war yeah James and
they had these big three-dimensional
terrain maps with hills and valleys on
them and rivers and people were putting
like Civil War units groups of [ __ ]
infantry in Canada [ __ ] and it was looks
like something out of a damn Napoleonic
warfare era generals [ __ ] command
post yeah yeah you know playing these
war games these old guys playing it well
that Star Trek game was kind of like
that there was older guys playing it
yeah I guess it would be because that
would be like the original series yeah
most of the original series like
audience at that time was yeah the older
so they were like already in their 30s
and 40s and they're playing these Star
Trek
war games yeah with these ships it looks
badass
the little ships that they bought I
remember seeing hanging them up and
everything they looked great
little bitty models somebody asked what
the
name of the hobby store in the 80s and
90s that also sold the indie stuff was
it Huntington's or something yeah that
yeah Huntington says if it was in
Huntington's mall yeah and in right
outside LA yeah I think it's called
Huntington's that's right and next to it
was a Lakewood skatepark ah yes that's
where I used to skate there yeah
let's skateboard yeah well who's in that
same area memory lane yeah there's in a
mall yeah but you didn't have to go into
the mall to access it it was like you
know that the door you could access it
from the outside of the mall from from
the parking lot I remember it might have
been called Huntington Huntington's yeah
I think so
yeah somebody they must be from that
area as well I remember we didn't uh cuz
I grew up in Daytona we only had one
really good hobby shop he was called
Dunn's toys it was on Beach Street and
we used to go there sometimes it was two
stories and they had like all the toys
and games like on the first floor but
then my favorite thing was the second
floor because that was where all the
model train [ __ ] was because my dad was
like really into model trains so we
would always go to that store and he
would go up there and see if there was
like new [ __ ] like little houses and
little trees and I'd always get to pick
out little little buildings and little
trees to put in it's like because he had
like a big huge thing in the garage I
don't wonder whatever happened to that
you only had that when I was a kid I
know one thing though that that place
where they were selling well at D&D
stuff that was the first time I'd ever
seen the [ __ ]
the artwork from like all those cone and
stuff oh yeah okay what was his name
Frank Rosetta Frank Frazetta they had
Frank pizzetta's everywhere and my
father my mind was [ __ ] blow yeah and
they were selling like lead statues and
statues of [ __ ] Conan with [ __ ]
like real super like voluptuous nude
[ __ ] women and [ __ ] it was it was a
great time yeah
there was no castle culture back then
none of this [ __ ] if it was [ __ ]
sexy it was there they can give a [ __ ]
well they still got that in costume God
is thank Christ about it but it was just
I think they're trying to actually no I
think they're true even trying to get
rid of anime because it's too sexual
they're trying to
so that I have never the only well I
mean I you know I've been keeping up
with they're trying to get rid all that
[ __ ] that's not gonna that's not gonna
have those boobs are too big that's what
they're saying those boobs are too big
women shouldn't look like that okay
everyone's got to be flat I'm gonna send
you in there to [ __ ] dispel that myth
all right so uh you want to UM wrap it
up we've been going for like 45 minutes
and I think it's starting to like thank
ya cuz it's Saturday and I still got to
do some recording before it gets too
late today trying to get rid of ring
girls and UFC it's all kind of [ __ ]
they're trying to get rid of Star Fleet
battles yeah yeah the panzer blitz was
that other one that he's yeah but that
must have been one of the I think it was
called Huntington's that sounds right
yeah see it's been a long time I was a
kid you know yeah and it was I think it
was in I think it was in Lakewood
because near it was Lakewood skatepark
yeah which is probably gone now I
remember I had bowls and tubes and
[ __ ] snakes and [ __ ] I could get in
there it's pretty neat
I don't think Daytona had a skate park
until [ __ ] maybe the mid 90s or
something like that maybe there early
nineties I hear they took away she was
curves yeah I haven't I didn't even know
they did it she rosemarys on they're
getting so [ __ ] uptight that they're
trying to desexualize everybody all the
men and all the women they all just
gonna look the same you're gonna look
like a little drone like something out
of them what was that [ __ ] science
fiction movie where they all had little
numbers a B and C and D negative and
[ __ ] and in the worker drones were
[ __ ] brave new world brave new world
an yeah the worker the worker drone
people and they were called D negatives
well no they they were just they they
were like caste system is I think they
were just ABCD and E
I hope yeah yeah well some of them are
like ace some were like in the book I
think from River Creek were asexual I
can't really read so well I read that in
high school and I hear it it that's then
yeah that's it they want everybody to be
whether it's there
not neither male in there female just a
drone you can try to make us drones I'm
too old to be worried about you do Yeah
right yeah worry about me I'm sure we're
gonna wrap it up for Saturday we'll be
back again tomorrow we'll probably do a
matinee
we'll find something a new movie to
watch tonight and review it tomorrow
probably about the same time because it
seems to be a good time for us to do it
it's about two o'clock in the afternoon
at least on Eastern Standard Time so
we'll see you guys again tomorrow and
thanks everybody for coming by